hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to let's
take a look at the Rocky
they certainly are a rollercoaster
aren't they in that they range from
cinematic genius to cinematic goofiness
the first film is a masterpiece and the
second feels just as epic but things
start to get a little weird after
Stallone starts directing whether you
like them or not there were definitely
some out there moments in the newer film
you got rocky going up against Don King
challenging the boxer half his age plus
fighting mr. t and Hulk Hogan in the
same movie yeah things got a little odd
in the rocky series but I think we can
all agree that the reigning champion of
goofiness simply has to be Rocky
[Music]
considered to be the biggest and
definitely the weirdest of the rocky
sequels this was a movie that certainly
seemed too big for its britches it was
to throw everything at you and as a
result it turns out a pretty silly flick
but it's just as much muscle flexing
montage shoving words luring an audience
shouting mayhem you'd expect from the
other films so it's a great or is it not
let's take a look at rocky 4 we opened
of course like the other sequels - with
a montage of the last film after rocky
and Apollo talking about how they're
both feeling older rocky makes it back
home to celebrate the birthday of fuck
god I will never get tired of Paulie is
there any greater image than him and the
birthday hand in a cigar OKs I heard
that you want a lot of pencil Paulie
where is so excited that it's time to
sweat that's right it's the shark jumper
5000 you think you've seen impressive
shark jumping another movie well this is
a fucking robot in a rocky film nothing
can stop it it's like putting a singing
giraffe in a Godfather movie no rhyme or
reason just pure insanity isn't it a
delight is this just a last thing you
think you see in this please make a
waste war make a wish like you said I
wish I wasn't in this nightmare
it's very class you wish very much what
do you think they're good oh look the
robot from Rocky just nodded in
agreement with him almost as if he can
understand what Stallone is saying and
actually interact off his emotion that
that's quite interesting it didn't know
something like that existed I mean here
I thought the world of the Academy Award
winning rocky was very similar to ours
you know very gritty and and very real
but I know apparently it's like a sci-fi
novel you can just go out and buy
artificially intelligent robots either I
didn't know that why does that exist but
while that's going on the Russians are
coming as they plan to challenge one of
America's best fighters against their
fighter named rank played by a man and
the Masters of marches and himself don't
today the Soviet Union has officially
entered a professional boxing Griego who
sources indicate was sculpted after an
Oscar is also genetically altered boxer
having experiments done on an involving
blood doping and anabolic steroids
so in fact Drago is a super boxer that's
right rocky is basically going up
against a video game character tell me
you wouldn't see that guy in punch out
or Street Fighter you can't because he's
basically just a big monster don't
believe me just listen to how he talks
yeah he doesn't talk he doesn't fucking
talk he has like 5 lines in his moving
they're all under 10 words he's
basically just a dragon a dragon for
Sylvester Stallone to defeat in fact is
just one letter off that's how little
they're hiding it the most of the world
is ignorant in volume I wish to educate
your culture if there been rumors of
blood doping anabolic steroids in the
Soviet Union experiments like your papa
he agent spinach every day Bernard Bravo
averages 1500 can shoot if I reveal the
results quite obvious whatever he is he
destroyed just will get the rocky
franchise by the way that's Brigitte
Nielsen playing during his wife yeah I
know
the idea for being married to a
brainless court because of the legal
drugs it's really quite astounding it
meanwhile back in Rocky's place a
puzzling Miss that he wants to go up
against the Russian stroganoff but his
friends are more hesitant purpose what
if this point in your life is worth
getting hurt four cameras
[Music]
lazy riding the next one it's my
favorite you're the greatest genius for
so long Polly
I will service you later like I was Sam
I don't want this chance to come over
here without no no no no it's not
working right now so now you can't just
recover from that I mean you can talk
about the final you want but all I'm
gonna think about Polly getting metal
hanjo seriously it's a fucking robot in
a rocket fell okay so as they sit around
watching recordings of them beating the
shit out of each other
you know the good old days Apollo finds
that he still didn't get all the
attention that he needed but once you're
step by that ranks die it's like ancient
history is it true you know I don't see
anybody asking for autographs could you
can I ask you something you think the
robot was a good idea but you know this
fight here having against the Russians I
think maybe it's like you get you maybe
the show is over an excuse me for you to
say you're still on top you still got to
Rocky movie and a rainbow coming your
way so you shut the fuck up
so of course Apollo agrees to fight
Drago as they announce it at a news
conference oh you know some folks got to
learn the hard way how do you think
Apollo should fight Drago I think the
first thing you'd better get Apollo the
latter feel the spar with the great
former champion I refer you to my first
our country Apollo Creed is well known
and very respected it'd be a good
victory whoa I didn't come here to loose
you hold on Elise you hold on
because lose and lose royally history
you are far too old to think that you
can win over drag is that a fact
yes and it could be a painful waha we
know we're supposed to see this taunting
before a boxing match but why do they
look so surprised about it jackal should
not even fight this mess if he hears
that has been right now
all my years if I had another box to
tell me that he was gonna win instead of
me what a shock what an absolute shock
and all the appointments that you
probably know oh snap he knocked over
the cardboard cutout probably because
there's more three dimensional than he
is but still yeah try not to wear
yourself out okay Oh Percy boo me I
I wouldn't mind postpone a couple weeks
postponed
that's right Apollo listen to your
friend the friend who had week to tell
you this and only way to right before
the fight to tell you to pull out so
Rocky doesn't convince him as the fine
it seems is finally about this start or
go into a Broadway musical
[Music]
I'll drag oh right now this is a weird
ass shit and just when you think the
film couldn't possibly get more surreal
James Brown because the Broadway musical
the Russian Superman and the talking
robot wasn't weird enough I don't know
what you guys normally do but in our
shall we just punch one another I'm Stu
Nahan and we welcome you for most
unusual event understatement of the
decade weighing 221 pounds of former
heavyweight champion of the world Apollo
crew and if anybody has seen that presen
presen rabbit please let me know you
boys know the rules
watch your low blows any punches rather
clean and no murdering I can't have this
I said no no murdering cause it's your
hands of messin it is ripped up it's
time to go to sleep oh shit
oh hey rocky what do you see we postpone
this robot to be blue folks
[Applause]
come on Apollo you can do it I have
faith in you
oh yeah Apollo's by doing burgers so
rocky being the faithful friend tries to
decide what is the right moment to
plumbing the time he decides to way to
deliver it
it appears to be a very serious
condition because the in phobia Tasha
evil Kent praises say you so Apollo
literally dies in the ring as rocky has
a few words to say at the funeral
you always did every to where you wanted
to remove scheduled fun on the side now
I'd just like to point out that if I
threw in the towel earlier I don't think
it would have made a difference
I don't think it's to me alive or
anything like that and yeah I'm just
gonna go now because um you're all
looking very angry at me so rocky
decides to fight Lego himself this of
course gets a lot of press from the
press
sue rush okay you are so fast and here
so very control Eisenberg's propoganda
who supported antagonistic and violent
violent shot seriously who invited
Paulie I mean what could he possibly
have to contribute to this poor you oh
my I'm young silent majority big my
applause did it Wally I told you to do
two things
shut up and not start an international
incident you can't do either so Rocky is
off to Russia to fight Franco everybody
in the world of course knows about it
except his wife what I just gotta do
what I gotta do you don't have to do it
you don't do this there's a lot of
people don't have a choice I do you're
willing to lose everything Mac it we all
know this bit let me just sum it up
rocky I come to bitching moaning you
about what you shouldn't fight and I the
wise genius have yet another bullshit
reason about why I should I can't
support you Oh fine
so you coming to the third act to
support me don't I always
who rocky goes for a drive we have a
montage in the air three movies for
reminding us of a time when we could
take him seriously as well if he says
goodbye to his son is a big giant man
wanted to be me up
are you real scared I'm gonna move
around you don't think you can it makes
all the difference in your life you know
dad maybe the real hero is the hero who
knows when to drop the sword you the
hero who doesn't get intimidated can
look after his wife and son Zuzu puts
his family first he came in here me
Kenya so rocky arrived in Russia as he
trains for the big fight the only way he
knows how
a training montage
[Music]
oh look Adrienne arrived to show her
support whoo what a surprise like just
the giant robot is watching the kid back
at home well enough of that so as you
can plainly see Draco is training his
body to be a heavyweight champion while
rocky is training his body to be Amish
equipment
and screw that stairs in Philadelphia
this time rocky actually manages to
climb a whole friggin Mountain
[Music]
[Applause]
till the day of the fire arrives and get
this Paulie suddenly becomes emotional
you know it's hard for me to say these
kind of things because that ain't my way
but if I could just unzip myself and
step out be someone else I want to be
you there's I'm not just saying that
because of drunk Isaac item pissed
myself by where does it go with this the
rocky Andrade of my Stretch Armstrong is
they all ride for the Russian national
[Music]
Wow Russians really treat their national
anthem a private respect I mean we have
that absolutely chief your Mira lost my
ball
and in this corner he is a Swedish actor
playing a Russian just to add double
insult to your country no longer it's
unbelievably ambition thank you ha
joke's on you the right side of his
mouth had already broken oh my god this
was a mistake I immediately regretted oh
wow is this guy - I can't people s
that's my body I don't remember who my
mother is
no II think I'm a cuckoo clock the more
I think about maybe the robot needs
assistance oh but of course rocky start
fighting back as the crowd slowly but
surely starts turning to Rocky saw a
beautiful beautiful of football you've
grabbed
[Applause]
yeah dimensions to Laura with this
[Music]
I do love these montages though you can
cut to anything and it would be epic
here all right
[Music]
[Applause]
soon
[Music]
finally rocky pulls together all his
strength and delivers the finishing
punches it was before Apollo this is for
Adrian this is for my son but this is
for uncle things but this is for I say
this is for that munchkin that
apparently hanged himself in the winter
/ - of course
having beaten Drago rocky makes a great
big speech about world peace yes I am
dead serious
I see a lot of people hating me and I
didn't know what to feel about that so I
guess I didn't like you much none either
you have to move to God you leap you
look tough during this fight I seen a
lot of changes he needs you at a lawyer
yet when you stop know these meanings
the way you felt about me in the way I
felt about you yep a shoe store store
with Tori is means you two guys showing
each other but I guess it's better than
20 million co2 most resolution there's a
drastic million of dollars the one of
China says if I can change yet the
moonstone Kosta Koufos music and you can
change we must refuse minutes every
father to say happy positive
[Applause]
yep there's absolutely nothing like a
place for world peace right after two
guys just beat that shit out of each
other is there yes listen to the
slurring man who beats people for a
living
purely he knows the way to enjoy his
peaceful world in fact I put it to you
has there ever been a speech about world
peace that has ever been more poignant
if a dog and a dolphin can get along why
can't our mom and dad
okay well this is a close second so
that's rocky for it's weird it's stupid
it's completely self-indulgent but I'd
be lying if I said it wasn't totally fun
to watch I mean it's up there with
movies like commando or Judge Dredd
there's just a real joy to its silliness
and over the top of way I mean obviously
it's not taken nearly as seriously as
the first two Rocky movies but there's
so much passion to it even though it
doesn't succeed at being serious you can
tell it's trying really hard and the
energy and commitment that's put into
this film as part of the plot even if it
does fail at an incredible level and
that's for me anyway good entertain I'm
a nostalgia critic now if you'll excuse
me I have to parade these words of peace
to the world
hey you know if I can change that and
you can change we can all yeah well okay
it was dog an adult we can learn to love
each other
[Music]
Oh